so I'm very glad to be here and thank
you guys for joining um so um mainly
today we're going to talk about JZ how
does JZ utilize this data for to enhance
and grow the business so I'll just share
my screen very quickly one
second
okay perfect so um so J's um we're as I
said we're going to talk about how does
it utilize this data to um enhance and
grow the business so first I introduce
the speakers so um first meass I'm the
lead data scientist here at JZ and with
me is my amazing coworker noar rugi as a
data scientist here in JZ which she will
cover the mainly the main project
technical part so we're going to go
first as an overview of the project and
then we're going to talk in detail for
one of our projects uh as with no
so um the first thing we're going to
talk about is what is jahz so um give
you guys an introduction about jahz uh
we're going to talk about the projects
in jazz so we split our projects into
two kinds the three pillars projects and
then the internal enablement the three
pillars are mainly for external uh
stakeholders and then the internal
enablement is for uh internal uh
departments and then enough will cover
the search Mist opportunities which is
one of our amazing internal enablement
projects and then we'll have the
Q&A so um just to give you guys an idea
about how much Jah is um generates data
so um so J is technically is a um so J
is not the group but the application um
is a food delivery application so pretty
much things like over style so pretty
much a driver delivers code to the
customer so just to give you guys about
the size of JZ so JZ is technically
started here in Saudi Arabia but is now
growing internationally in Kuwait and
Bahrain and other countries so um just
to give you guys an idea about the
growth and the size so J has technically
now in 2022 has the driver has driven
450 million kilometers which is almost
a, trip to the moons so um so that gives
you an idea about the data being
generated either spatial information
about the drivers or the customer base
orders in a daily manner um so just to
give you a perspective so first we're
going to talk about Jah group the
overall umbrella and then the three
pillars so Jah group as an umbrella is
it's a big umbrella um and it contains a
lot of other companies and uh systems um
some of them are in the ecosystem for
the restaurants which is Marin for for
example point of sale for the
restaurants and then for Logistics we
have San and J aonomus San is our
dispatching kind of system so we give um
drivers uh orders to deliver and then we
have J tonomous as um our R&D based uh
delivery um system so things like drones
Etc and then for the Commerce we have
also pick as a retail last mile delivery
and then we have blue store which is our
Sports uh application so people buy
tickets um they book um I don't know um
Fields Etc and then we have Jus which is
the main talk we're going to have today
uh it's about J Flagship which is the
application for that is being used by
the users um for to order food for um
yeah to order food from other
restaurants and then there's Jazz
insights which is the um the portal for
the restaurants to gain insights about
their orders customers operations and
then we have Coit which is um a cloud
kitchen based
company so what are the three pillars of
jahz um so jahz technically to simplify
it as much as we can we have customers
we have drivers and then we have
restaurants so the customers pretty much
orders opens the application orders food
from a restaurant the restaurant accepts
that order and then a driver is
dispatched to uh pick up that order and
deliver it to the customer um So
currently our customer base is growing a
lot uh we have reached up to 600 more
than 600,000 customers open our app
daily and Order and then we have 40K
drivers delivering gos and then more
than 25,000
branches so
uh our data and Di projects we act
technically split it into two we have
these products that we build for
external use by the consumer and
consumers which could be any one of the
three pillars the customer the
restaurant or the driver uh to enhance
their experience personalize uh the
application for them uh Etc and then we
have the internal projects and these are
targeted for our internal uh mostly
business departments so I'm talking here
sales marketing um Etc and product
team so um first I'm going to go through
some of our external projects so um
these are uh the sample of the projects
we did so first one we're going to to go
through is end of year
2022 uh so this uh project was mainly
focused at giving it's a fun project
pretty much so giving users um giving
users um fun facts about their uh usage
Behavior about food uh which is actually
quite fun if you think about it uh what
kind of food do I like uh is there any
specific behavior I have that is unique
in my exploring options in jazz or do I
like specific type of restaurants or do
I explore a lot of other restaurants uh
so it gives you just these kind of
insights for our users for fun so we did
this in 2022 and we're going to release
soon the 2023 version and then we have
our explore page so um JZ contains an
explore page and and this is pretty much
a page for the customers to explore so
um if a customer for um don't know what
to order they just um they need help uh
ordering food um so pretty much expore
is our personalized helping page uh for
our users so we provide a lot of
products in over there but some of them
are our recommendation engine So based
on the customer um food preferences what
kind of Cuisines they like uh we will
recommend restaurants for them and then
we have also popular restaurant pics
which is a pretty much an interesting
kind of feature so um we showcase
customers U the restaurants that in a
democracy based way what kind of um
restaurants the other people are
ordering at this time so at 5: PM what
people are ordering right now then I'll
give this option to the other customers
and then we have what's trending which
is pretty much what's currently trending
in restaurants in J so imagine a
restaurant that is just peaked people
are all over that restaurant it's
trending in Tik Tok and in X or Twitter
Etc and people are all over that
restaurant so you want to always
showcase that to the user just for them
to be part of the roller coaster if that
makes sense and then we also have our
restaurant insights project so our
restaurant insights project is mainly
targeted for our restaurants so we
showcase uh restaurants um very nice
analytics about their customer base for
them to understand and tailor their
brand for them and then we give them
also operational analytics so we give
them um let's say analytics that should
help them improve their operational
day-to-day activity so we give them idea
about which items are being delayed or
delaying their orders etc for them to
optimize that item preparation and then
we also give them basket analysis for
them to optimize their baskets or menus
sorry for their menu and then many many
more other anal
and the last project I'm going to talk
about for our excellent project is our
Cuisine classification so um so the data
data and Di Department was established
in JZ one year and a half ago and um
there were 44 there were 13 Cuisines at
that time and they were pretty much
manually um made uh and since they are
manually made you could expect mistakes
and also if you think about it very well
13 Cuisines does not cover all of the
restaurants types that exist in the
market so uh we've come with an idea to
build this NLP based model to predict
the cuisine of each restaurant and then
we had a target of 44 Cuisines which
includes Chinese Japanese Thai ETC
American etc etc and then we want to
predict the cuisine of each restaurant
based on their restaurant name and their
menu so we pick up they have and then we
try to to analyze what kind of Cuisine
that is and if you think about it some
restaurant even have multiple Cuisines
so one restaurant can sell Chinese and
Japanese food and then we also need to
take that into consideration that we
need to have multiple Cuisines per
restaurant um so yeah so we built this
NLP based model to predict the multiple
cuines of each restaurant based on their
um items and then classify them as soon
as they join and then include them in
our application in the
homepage so what did the products do so
in one year and a half technically we uh
jah's orders 15% of J's orders come from
the these data products that I just
talked about so 15% of the revenue that
is coming in from our Jas application is
being impacted by these products and we
we've seen a very interesting thing that
users that use the uses these data
products they usually have a 26%
decrease in their average customer order
cycle so you always want to aim for that
when you're building your product you
want to reduce the time that customer
takes to check out pretty much so we've
seen this amazing statistic that it's
being produced by 26 which is quite a
lot um so yeah that's pretty much
concludes the external based projects
that we have here in jazz and then I'm
gonna now um transfer you guys to no uh
what she will explain in detail in
technical detail um one of our very
interesting internal projects our Search
opportunity
so I'll hand it up to
no one
sec yeah you can go now one sec I'll
check I think she's have
okay hello
everyone hello no your mic is fine okay
uh thank you so much Basel and hello
everybody um my name is no and I'll be
introduced in one of the data in AI
internet projects at jahas the search
missed opportunities project this
project aims to analyze the search
queries within the app to identify the
commercial
opportunities um first off the search
function is one of the most widely used
functions in jahas and um 55% of jahas
orders come come from the search
function and it is usually used by
someone who's looking for something
specific either a restaurant or an i
so the problem is that some people um
are looking for restaurants that do not
exist in jahas and these are what we
call the M opportunities so the goal of
this project is to capture these uh
restaurants the M opportunities and on
board them on
jahz our Target is the jahz uh sales
team we try to guide them into signing
up with the restaurants that are highly
demanded by our
customers and rather than uh having a
subjective approach of selecting
restaurants to on board they will follow
a data driven
approach the project is uh the project
starts with collecting the search data
we collect a one week long um search
record uh within the app and then we
perform some query checks text
similarity checks to match the uh search
queries with the restaurant name the
restaurant names that we have in jahas
and then we remove the item names to um
since that some of the search queries
are intended for items rather than
restaurants so we should remove them um
to uh finalize a list of full of
restaurant
names and then the final step will be
matching the Arabic and English names uh
the queries that have a similar
pronunciation will be matched
together so starting up with collecting
the search data we collect a one week
long uh record of searches within the
app in addition to the uh restaurants
that got clicked on during these uh
sessions and then we perform
sessionization we take the queries that
have a time difference of 5 Seconds or
less and we group them together taking
the longest string in that
session as you can see here we have an
example of three queries that uh have a
time difference of less than 5 Seconds
the first two will be removed and the
last one which is the longest one will
be kept
then we group queries by similarity we
use the Lenin distance algorithm to uh
find the text similarity between queries
and the leein distance is basically the
number of changes that you you will
perform to a word in order to transform
it to another so in this example we have
pick and pick the first one is pick
without a k and the other is with a K
and the distance between them is one
because we're only adding the letter K
so these two two will be grouped
together then we'll start doing the uh
quity checks we have four query checks
to uh find the similarity between the
search queries in the app and the
restaurants that we have in
jahas the first check is the substring
on clicked restaurants We compare the
queries that were written written by the
uh users with the with the restaurant
names that they clicked on with the
restaurants that they clicked on and we
see if the
um query is a substring of the
restaurant name that they have clicked
on it'll be matched and it will be ex
excluded queries that do not pass the
first check will be moving on to the
second check which will compare which
will also be Subs on city restaurants so
this time instead of the uh taking the
restaurants that got clicked on we take
all the restaurants in that City that
the search was performed in and we
compared the queries with the restaurant
names in this case we have the quid
Earth which match the Earth Cafe uh
restaurant
in the next step is spelling mistakes
correction we uh built a dictionary for
each restaurant of all the possible
frequent substs of that restaurant name
so for example we have the restaurant
name tuxedo and we have three possible
uh frequent subst strings uh that we
found in the search tux tux seed and Tux
without a KN so if we have have a query
that's two Zed it will be matched with
tux seed since the distance will be one
and this row will be eliminated and
excluded the final check is finding the
distance between the queries and all
jah's restaurants taking um all the
queries and all the restaurants in Jes
and finding the Lenin distance between
them so if we have a query of Starbucks
in the city jeda it will be matched with
Starbucks that is that is in r and it
will be flagged found in country in
order to find the Reston that exist in
cities and do not exist in other
cities after performing all the checks
we move on to the item names removal
step where we uh have a list of the most
frequent words that that can that were
in the menu item names in jahas and then
the queries that uh fully that are
entirely consisting of um common item
words will be removed
the final step is the Arabic English
names matching using the soundex
algorithm we find the sound of each quy
and we group the ques based on their
sound if they're pronounced the same
then they will be combined taking the
quy that has the highest
frequency the final output would be a
dashboard to showcase the uh week's um
missed opportunities on the left we can
see that there's a top 10 um a chart of
of top 10 alltime m opportunities since
the beginning of this project and on the
right we have the top 10 Uprising Mist
opportunities for the new missed
opportunities of this week and on the
bottom we can have we can see that we
have a list a detailed list of alltime
Miss
opportunities the impact of this project
is huge uh within two months hundreds of
restaurants join jahas through the
missed opportunities dashboard and the
converion rate of the missed
opportunities is double the conversion
rate of the restaurants that uh joined
outside the missed
opportunities um and the revenue as well
is um uh 20% of the total revenue of the
um restaurants that recently joined
jahas thank you so much for your
attention and we're ready to uh have
your
questions okay um
yeah yeah that is a great presentation
both thank
you thank you man and
um gu there's a question for you enough
from Mar you would like
to oh
yeah okay that's a good question thank
you Marcus um yes for sure we uh are
trying to uh we also we do have plans
for enhancing um uh this project and
using like more complicated and Advanced
Techniques uh for better uh results we
uh certainly tried embeddings um and
we're still trying uh but the results so
far are so good and um I think
embeddings would be better for um you
know techs that have a meaning rather
than restaurant names because that
probably wouldn't help that
much so
yeah
oh um so there's a question from fad
what platforms are you using in narrow
down these quiz to restaurant
names um so
um so I know can you answer fad
questions or should I go for
it um so so technically F what we do is
that there are these um applications in
the market pretty much that captures uh
events and we're capturing the events
where people um write um their quiz in
the search function and then so what we
do is that we try uh our best our best
to um combine these um search queries um
to be at their final stage so pretty
much imagine someone for example WR in
McDonald's so first they write the m and
then the C and then the D so pretty much
we always try to get the longest one one
he wrote uh that is not very different
from the others or the previous query
and um as soon as we get that sometimes
the users write a full restaurant name
but most of the time they just write the
beginning of that name and then they
just expect it to uh showcase um in the
in the results so um so pretty
much uh most the users write enough
letters to capture at least one word uh
of the name of the restaurants and then
in one of these checks they will be
captured so in the best case scenario
when they write McDonald's MCD so and
then they click on the McDonald's uh
restaurant then it will be matched in
the first check in no's presentation
where uh MCD is a substring of
McDonald's and then it will be just
filtered out as
um um so yeah it will pretty much be
excluded and as a restant it already
exists in
um there is another one from um Lawrence
uh is it possible to have access to your
slides um um unfortunately honestly um I
I don't think we can share it I I'll see
if there is any possible way to um share
it to you guys after we get um some
approvals for it but I I I really doubt
it so yeah sorry about
that